see the water EJ so you're here to do a
debt free scream how much have you paid
off two hundred and thirty four thousand
dollars Wow
fifty months where Jason is Stephanie
Estrada we're from El Segundo California
and this is my gym that we're in Estrada
fitness club little shout out there and
the website is that it's trying to
fitness doc there we go all right there
we go open the business we got married
we had a child our son DJ all walking on
a day when we have goals to reach in our
lives we attack them together
we're obedient God will bless us so we
keep that in in our heart in our mind so
that when we are attempted we can go
right back to what we know that's why I
do what I do because when a client is
just not believing in themselves you see
them do it they look back and say wow I
did it and they become a professional at
overcoming obstacles and that's what we
produce here in Australia fitness so 50
months ago four years ago basically 50
months what happened that made you guys
say okay we're changing everything and
our parents it's very private I still to
this day I don't know what their money
situation was my mother and father both
took out loans for school or what have
you
we both had you know not known each
other my father had given me the Total
Money Makeover by Dave Ramsey and he's
like I wish I woulda did this long time
ago so I listened to the audio book
every day to work around that same time
Stephanie's mother I gave her her the
book she knew like struggled with money
you know crying over not have enough
money but I read it in like a day
because I just read things really fast
and it made sense but you know I wasn't
really following the plan yet Stephanie
had all these purchases that she kind of
was just like couldn't afford or she was
like on the edge of a 40 and one of them
was hiring me as her personal trainer
before we were even together I'm a
dental hygienist in the dental office I
work at is just right around the corner
from the gym and I was making you know
good money and every every dime was
going out I bought a BMW I joined a
high-end gym and I met with a financial
advisor and she pretty much told me no
one's gonna marry you with this kind of
debt so I had to make some hard
decisions and my fun little BMW is
coming up on renewal time
I sold it I was under I had to give him
like $2,000 but it really helped it took
almost eight hundred two thousand
dollars off of my plate every month and
when I got rid of my car I have my
scooter and it's awesome actually
I love having no car
at that point we had already committed
to one another and we started just you
know going forward before we got married
he's like okay we'll each save $500 and
I looked at him like he was crazy like
you want me to do what like where am I
gonna get this $500 and I said I won't I
don't think if we can't save together we
shouldn't be getting married
and she's like pouting whatever how am I
gonna say $500 I said you can do it we
were listening to your show and we heard
people you know giving their testimonies
and their stories and you were like you
know what this is like motivating they
flipped a switch for us and then she's
like wait we can pay for we can really
pay for our wedding cash we didn't take
out any loans and that was the beginning
of our journey we just felt like we were
literally in his own you can tell us
nothing at that point like I tell my
clients it was go time but you kept with
it yeah we kept with it with just our
faith in God and we listened to you and
that's when we really decided to to get
gizelle intense we were listening to
your show and then next thing you know
we went from a few grand and we were
setting goals were like alright this
month we're gonna throw thirteen
thousand edit this month and we just had
no idea how real the debt snowball was
and then I got pregnant and he was born
in May 2015
so we said by the end of 2015 we're
gonna have it paid off and it didn't
look possible but it actually happened
we attacked them together we work out
together we're on the same page as far
as grocery shopping even we incorporate
Elijah and a lot of our workouts
together we don't make any excuses to
why we can't reach our goals from a
physical standpoint
and I think that's really what allows us
to transfer that over to the financial
side on our phones in our cars every
road trip every time we went to the
grocery store and even when we're at
home we were listening to Dave Ramsey
Elijah knew the phrase
you live like no one else so one day you
can live up and give like no one else I
can remember planning to fly to
Nashville and do the debt-free scream
she said hey I have a surprise for you
do you know what it is and I said I
don't know what it is and so we get to
the airport and I see on the big screen
Nashville and I'm like Dave Ramsey and
she's like yeah see my shirt what's it
say I can't see the bottom says Dave is
my homeboy love it
we don't have an example and most of our
age group and friends like we are the
example all of our friends have made fun
of us you know try to test our toughness
when you can't endure that they'll then
come to you and ask for help my name is
Megan Logan and I'm from El Segundo
California I met Jason and Stephanie
straight out of college I moved out to
California to fulfill my an internship
based on my career and I was riding in
the car with Jason Stephanie one day and
they were listening to Dave on the
podcast and together they started
talking about their vision and where
they wanted to see the direction of
their life and that aligned with my
vision too so I got in to the program
and accountability is key Jason and I
are both personal trainers and Stephanie
takes fitness very seriously as well and
we find that when we coach our clients
account they come to us to have an
accountability partner and that's what
we found with Dave with the program as
well as with each other we got to do our
debt-free screams on the same day god
blessed me by putting me with Jason
Stephanie I think my parents planted
that seed and Jason Stephanie helped it
grow it's been phenomenal oh you're
awesome I love it Meghan we want to
continue
at that legacy with people who were
around with people we encounter so my
dad gave me the book and tells me how
before he took out loans for school or
whatever it will have you and he's able
to see how is working in my life and so
for Christmas this year
I thought it'd be great to repay him and
giving him the Chris Hogan retire
inspired book he's like thanks you know
this is the best gift that someone could
give me and I thought that was great
hey gosh thank you for making a trip all
the way out here we're honoured and
beautiful baby he's also he's grinning
and happy and look at it he said life is
good he's a ham and we went on the show
Elijah was eight months and now Elijah
is 21 months and Elijah will remember
this forever being able to change the
family tree and make our son's life even
better than ours and then our parents is
the coolest thing ever I want our son to
have more deeper values other than
material things I wanted to know how he
got his stuff not just those given to
him the aspect of working out working
hard it all starts with a plan you want
to become financially fit it starts with
a plan then free and loving it